Using a game engine for linear animation can be intimidating for the uninitiated.
It requires learning new terminology that the average DCC software user is unlikely
to be familiar with.
Being very modular in nature, Unreal breaks down its world construction and animation
features with an array of new technological engine terms that unfortunately have no equivalent
in classical digital film production.
These terms are directly related to the process of building a game, but once you learn them,
you'll come to appreciate their logic and capabilities.
Static meshes and scale meshes describe different types of actors based on whether or not they
have joint-based deformable geometry.
Unreal also uses different terms for objects in the scene, like actors, pawns, and characters.
The environment is described in terms of the world, maps, levels, and sub-levels.
Level sequences are where you control and keyframe your actors in Sequencer, and control rigs
are like animation rigs.
Games are used for triggering specific actions or for different visual looks.
Blueprints are a visual scripting system, and source control is a way to check in data
in and out of your project using a server depot.
However, Sequencer's feature set attempts to mirror some of the terminology you're more
familiar with in film production like scene assemblies, takes, layouts, shots, and sequences.
Unreal's project structure and logic has been designed to essentially replicate the
operations of film production.
The project is the film, and each layer of complexity in Unreal replicates the specific
set of responsibilities in the film and its crew.
Large sophisticated structures within Unreal are broken down into smaller and smaller components,
which grant the user the ability to replicate the intricate requirements of production.
Sequencer is also capable of replicating different shooting styles.
Classical cinematography recognizes the master scene technique, which can be directly replicated
in Unreal using a single level sequence, multiple cameras, and a camera cuts track.
Whereas the triple take technique is matched by what you're learning today, using nested
level sequences and layered sub-scene tracks to create the illusion of continuity by the
editing of multiple level sequence shots and having your actors hit specific marks.
Each methodology works to organize the necessary roles in production ranging from lighting
to set construction to performance.
So it's not a coincidence that sequencer's level sequence and assembly structure bears
a direct similarity to the organization of film production.
A typical film is broken down into acts, sequences, scenes, shots, and takes.
Each unit is smaller than the last, and they're effectively nested inside of one another.
On the Unreal side, sequencer is designed to replicate film structure by using level
sequences.
These actors can create levels of organization through nesting level sequences into one another.
This will allow organizational control over scenes, actors, cameras, lights, keyframes,
and other technical capabilities.
Since level sequences are essentially virtual containers, they're capable of handling
greater and greater orders of animation complexity as more level sequences are added to them.
For new users, it can be confusing to realize that a level sequence actor can accommodate
so many different tasks while still just being called a level sequence.
You may hear me say a level sequence shot or a level sequence sequence, but they're
all level sequence actors being used in different ways.
So try not to be confused by the word level sequence.
Here's an example of what a nested level sequence looks like.
I've loaded the SEQ multi-shot EX level sequence that we'll be recreating during the hands-on
exercise.
It consists of a level sequence with shots with multiple level sequence shots inside
of it.
The level sequence with shots can possess an array of shots through the use of a shot
track.
Level sequence shots can be moved, trimmed, or have their play rate altered.
You can even generate alternate takes using the take system, or fade up from black using
the fade track.
The structure of a nested level sequence can be nearly anything, especially for game
construction purposes.
But for cinematics and linear content creation, there are usually some core ingredients.
Inside each level sequence shot, you'll have level actors like props or characters to animate.
A minimum of one camera per nested level sequence shot is needed whether it's possessible or
spawnable, and most importantly a camera cuts track is required to generate footage.
Another option is to use what is known as a sub-scene track.
This is another form of nested level sequence that functions like a layer.
If you're familiar with After Effects, it's very similar to a pre-composition or pre-comp.
Sub-scene tracks can be used for animation, camera moves, effects, or specific lighting
setups.
When played in sequence, the level sequence with shots pulls the camera binding data from
each shot's camera cuts track, so it knows which camera it's looking through and what
needs to be rendered.
The result is a continuous sequence when played back through the timeline.
This completes this brief examination of a nested level sequence.
Let's move on to our next module, where we'll take a look at some sequencer features and
tools.